the other impossible task of giving a
whirlwind
overview of the philosophy of
objectivism
the philosophy of iran yeah so luckily
she did it in an essay
or she she talks about doing her
philosophy on one foot
um but let me integrate it with the
literature and with her life a little
bit
she wanted to be a writer but her goal
she had a particular goal in her writing
she was an idealist right she wanted to
portray the ideal man
so one of the things you do when you
want to do something is what is an ideal
man you have to ask that question what
does that mean
you might have a sense of it you might
have certain glimpses of
glimpses of it in other people's
literature but what is it
so she starts reading philosophy to try
to figure out what a philosopher say
about the ideal man
and what she finds horrifies her in
terms of the view of most philosophers
of man and and
she's she's attracted certainly when
she's young to nietzsche because
nietzsche at least has a vision of
of grandeur for man even though his
philosophy is very flawed and has other
problems and contradicts
man in many ways but at least he has
that vision of what is possible
to man and she's attracted to that
romantic vision that idealistic vision
so she discovers in writing and
particularly in writing out of the rug
but even in the fountain
that she's going to have to develop her
own philosophy she's going to have to
discover
these ideas for herself because they're
not fully articulated anywhere else
they glimpses again of it in
in aristotle in nietzsche but they're
not fully fleshed out
so to a large extent she develops a
philosophy
for a very practical purpose to write
to write a novel about the ideal man and
and alice shrugged
is the manifestation of that by the way
sorry and to interrupt uh
as a little aside she does when you say
man you mean human
and the i mean because we'll bring this
up often
she does i mean maybe you can elaborate
of how
she specifically uses man and he and the
work we live in a time now
yes so well she did that in
in in the sense that everybody did it
during her period of time right it's
only in modern times where we do heaps
last sheet
right it historically when you said he
you meant
a human being unless the particular
context implied that it was a
but in iron man's case in this case in
this one sentence
she probably meant man not that
because she she viewed that there are
differences between men and women but
not the same which
i know comes at a shock to many people
but
um she she's working on a character
she was working on a particular vision
right yeah
she considered herself a man worshipper
and a man not not human being a male
male she worshiped manhood if you will
the
the the the hero in man and she wanted
to fully understand what that was
now it has massive implications for
ideal woman and i think she does portray
the ideal woman in in
in atlas shrugged in the character of
dagny
but her goal is
you know i think her selfish goal for
what she wanted to get out of the novel
is that excitement partially sexual
about seeing your ideal manifest in
reality of what you perceive as the
that which you would be attracted to
fully intellectually physically sexually
in every
aspect of your life that's what she's
trying to bring so there was no
ambiguity of gender so there was the
masculinity and the femininity in her
work
very much so and if you read the novels
you you see that
you see that now remember this is in the
context of
in atlas shrugged she is portraying a
woman
who runs a railroad the most masculine
of all jobs you can imagine right
running a railroad better than any man
can run it yes
and achieving huge success better than
any other man out there
but but for her
even dagny needs somebody to
needs a man in some sense
to look up to yeah and that's
the character whose name i will mention
because it gives away too much of the
plot but
there has to be i like how you do that
you're good
you're not a lot of friends not
brilliant because you convey all the
important things without giving away
plot lines that's beautiful you're a
master
so she's so she's very much
she she described herself once
as a male chauvinist okay she
very she likes the idea of a man opening
a doofer
but more metaphysically she identifies
something in the difference between a
way a man relates to a woman in a woman
relates to man it's not
the same
you